♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est un peu un reçu de caisse
de l'époque de Mésopotamie.
vieille de 4000 ans.
Une des surprises que nous
avait réservées Éric Bouchard.
Passionné d'histoire, il est
bibliothécaire aux collections
spécialersrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsr.
- C'est peut-être être
d'une certaine culture.
- L'Université a été fondée
en 1878 seulement, mais
les trésors littéraires
de toutes les époques.
rares, coll. spéciales, UdeM
- C'est du 12e siècle quand
même. Le plus vieux manuscrit
complet qui nous est parvenu
du Moyen-âge. Un document tr
hein, avec des ailes de bois,
la partie en parchemin
et vous avez le corp
l'ouvrage qui est sur papier.
Un manuel d'histoire ancienne
et moderne préparé par un grand-
Donc, on est en 1788.
C'est ici qu'on peut conserver
plus de 50 000 documents
à température et taux
- Au fil des ans,
la bibliothèque a été
enrichie grâce à des
instituts de rlelelelelelelelels
ou religieux qui ont donné
leurs coll E E E E En tout,
- Du côté francophone,
c'est sans doute une des...
très belles et des très riches.
Littérature, archite
sciences, histoire bien entendu,
histoire du Canada, ça a été
un point fort important.
- D'un manuel de physiqu
- Fait par Jacob Gariépy,
un médecin de la Pra
Donc, qui date de 1839.
originaux du fameux "Refus
Glauauauauauaul-Émile Borduas.
- On se retrouve ici danslelelen
principale de la bibliothèque.
- Bon à savoir : la bibliothèque
- S'ils ont un intérêt
particulier pour consulter,
ils pesisisisisisisisisisisisisn
c'est les premiers mardis
deisisisisisis. L'idée, en gros,
c'est de pouvevevevevevevevevev,
ces richesses documentaires.- -s
curiosités, comme cet almanach;e
la bibliothèque. Ou bien
cet ouvrage de prophéties
- Et il va jusqu'en 2023!
Donc en 2023, il nous prédit
sec. L'automne sera moite
et venteuse. L'hiver sera
tempéré.- - - - - - - - - - - -e
prince débonnaire devraitmomomoe
du Royaume de France.
Radio